Let's get back to the phones at six one seven
eight three zero. Forty seven fifty.
I want to talk to our caller from the two
oh two area code. Who's calling today from
two zero to.
Hi, David. This is Rachel from the Maryland
State of Emergency.
Love it. And Rachel. You don't have us on
speaker phone to.
I do not. You're on a headset. Are you unable
to hear me?
You know, it's OK. I think we can deal with
it.
OK.
So my question to you is around like the corporate
liability shield. It seems like that McConnell
bright red line. And he doesn't care about
anything else. My question to you is, do you
think this is something the Democrats came
from cave on? I mean, they kind of have to
kind of posture it around, not, you know,
that being a nonstarter. Well, I mean, basically,
the language that was submitted came from,
you know, Cuomo liability shield, Becky, you
know, put it in New York to use in New York.
So, Rachel, let me explain to people first
what you're talking about. So people now,
so the idea here is Donald Trump floated this
starting a couple of months ago. The idea
is a liability shield for businesses who reopen
where they would not be subject to a lawsuit
or or criminal or civil proceedings of any
kind.
If people catch corona virus at their place
of business, it could be employees and it
could be customers. The idea being, if a business
thinks, wait a second, if my employees get
sick or customers get sick, I could get sued.
They'd be less likely to open. So Donald Trump's
side as a way to really encourage businesses
to open. You know, I I would have my answer
two weeks ago. Rachel might have been more
definitive at this point. I think everything
is on the table. I think given what's going
on and given how far apart the negotiations
seem to be, Democrats more than Republicans
seem extremely eager to get money to people
and get money in people's hands that they
might be willing to concede.
I would not. It's a question mark for me.
I wouldn't put anything past anyone at this
point, particularly when you've got an election
in three months. And so a lot of the players
who are up for reelection in the Senate are
going to be thinking about what they're willing
to do versus what they're willing to give
up in order to facilitate getting reelected
as well. So it's a crapshoot right now. Anything
could happen.
Yeah, I mean, I'm just very concerned that
it could lead to a potential fight. Because
once you have people who are absolved of liability,
then their interest in trying to do everything
they can to maintain worker and consumer safety
becomes a little lax. I mean, you saw what
happened in the nursing homes in New York.
So I'm just that that's really what is concerning
to me, is that it lead to a further.
Well, listen, the answer is yes. And of course,
we may be on the way to a further spike anyway.
And we were supposed to have a break between
wave one and two. It's not clear that's going
to happen. So all these factors are going
to add. It's looking like it's going to be
a very difficult fall in the United States.
Absolutely. Great. Thanks, David. Thanks,
Rachel. Appreciate the phone call.